[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia perú vive días turbulentos su
política languidece una vez más en los
ya 30 años por los que han pasado seis
presidentes salpicados por escándalos de
corrupción uno de ellos alan garcía se
suicidó el 17 de abril de 2019 cuando la
policía de lima se dirigía a su casa
para arrestarlo por las acusaciones de
corrupción que pesaban en su contra
garcía fue uno de los cuatro presidentes
consecutivos que habrían recibido
millonarios sobornos por parte de la
empresa brasileña odebrecht
de acuerdo con la fiscalía peruana que
adelantó el caso el segundo gobierno de
garcía habría recibido cerca de 24
millones de dólares de parte de
odebrecht tanto para financiar la
campaña a la presidencia como para
beneficiar a los brasileños en la
construcción de obras relacionadas con
el metro de lima y la carretera
interoceánica en 2018 garcía pidió asilo
político en la embajada de uruguay
alegando una presunta persecución
política pero el presidente tabaré
vázquez se negó esto dijo garcía justo
después
es importante confiar en lo que ha dicho
el presidente de la republica del
presidente del poder judicial de que hay
independencia de poderes y que no hay
persecución política poco más de cuatro
meses después de estas declaraciones
alan garcía decidió ponerle fin a su
vida a sus 69 años de edad y antes de
que él fuera presidente alejandro toledo
había sido mandatario de los peruanos
del 2001 al 2006 pero cuando en enero de
2017 la justicia peruana se aprestaba
para ponerle prisión preventiva durante
el curso de las investigaciones de
odebrecht toledo escapó eeuu dos años
más tarde en julio 2019 fue arrestado a
petición del ministerio público peruano
pero en marzo de 2020 fue liberado bajo
fianza
actualmente toledo es pedido en
extradición por perú por dos procesos en
los cuales se le acusa de haber recibido
20 millones de dólares de parte de
odebrecht para la construcción de la
carretera interoceánica
y justamente esa carretera interoceánica
es uno de los puntos neurálgicos del
entramado de corrupción de odebrecht en
el perú durante la presidencia de toledo
quien fungía como ministro de economía
era pedro pablo kuczynski años más tarde
kuczynski sería elegido presidente para
el período 2016 2021 pero en menos de
dos años al mando fue destituido por el
congreso tras haber sido acusado de
recibir en su época de ministro coimas
de parte de odebrecht para facilitarle a
la multinacional la construcción de la
polémica carretera interoceánica
pienso que lo mejor para el país es que
yo renuncie a la presidencia de la
república- tras la renuncia de pedro
pablo kuczynski también conocido como
ppk lo sucedió su vicepresidente martín
vizcarra el caso de vizcarra es
particular porque como presidente
disolvió el congreso en lo que llamó una
cruzada contra la corrupción pero tras
más de dos años en el poder el propio
congreso lo destituyó por unos presuntos
actos de corrupción de cuando vizcarra
fue gobernador de la región de moquegua
a pesar que vizcarra negó dichas
acusaciones y sin haberse expuesto
pruebas fehacientes en su contra el
congreso decidió inhabilitarlo
vamos vamos
[Música]
no voy a ir a ninguna embajada
no me voy a internar ni una clínica
matar y mi domicilio contribuyendo con
todas las investigaciones hablemos de
otro presidente ollanta humala fue
mandatario de los peruanos del 2011 al
2016 en las elecciones que lo llevaron a
la presidencia se enfrentó a keiko
fujimori hija de alberto fujimori y le
ganó por un estrecho margen justamente
de esa época electoral es de lo que se
le investiga de acuerdo con la fiscalía
peruana y con testimonios de las cabezas
directivas de odebrecht humala y su
esposa nadine heredia habrían recibido
tres millones de dólares como
financiación de campaña por lo pronto el
ex presidente y la ex primera dama
afrontan el curso de investigación en
libertad habiendo recorrido brevemente
los procesos en contra de cinco
presidentes peruanos escuchemos uno de
los más sonados el de alberto fujimori
fujimori fue presidente del perú de 1990
al año 2000 pero en 1992 propinó un
autogolpe de estado intervino el
congreso
cortes y varias instituciones de manera
ilegal con mano de hierro y convicción
autoritaria gobernó por dos mandatos
seguidos sin embargo llegado el año 2000
el escándalo de los vladivideos
sentenció su final por vladivideos se
conoce a una serie de grabaciones que
estaban en posesión de vladimiro
montesinos ex asesor presidencial de
fujimori en ellos se podía ver una gran
cantidad de sobornos que fujimori pagaba
para que diversos funcionarios del
gobierno la iglesia los medios de
comunicación y las altas esferas del
perú se pusieran a disposición suya y a
los intereses del fujimorato
actualmente fujimori con 82 años purga a
prisión en lima por varios delitos que
no sólo atañen la corrupción así pues
perú se muestra en evidencia como uno de
los países de américa latina donde la
corrupción es sistemática y la
legitimidad de las instituciones
tambalea indignado el pueblo protesta y
se apresta a escoger en 2021 a un nuevo
presidente llega
al final de este capítulo soy andrés
suárez jaramillo gracias por compartir
estas historias que las encuentran en
los programas de france 24 punto com
[Música]